I'm Alexa von Tobel  the founder and CEO of LearnVest.com,...
...the leading site for women and their money.
When you're getting married, how are you really supposed to join your finances?
Some people opt to completely join their accounts entirely.
Others opt to keep them completely separate.
My favorite option though is a hybrid model.
Here's how I think about it.
Let's say you take home 4,000 dollars a month and he takes home 3,000 dollars a month.
What you would do is each puts 75 percent of what you take home into an "our" account.
That would give you about 5,250 dollars each month for rent, utilities,...
...a vacation that you're striving for,...
...but that really lets you live your lives together and spend together.
Each of you would then take 25 percent of what you take home and that would mean...
...you would have about 1,000 dollars in your own separate "fun" fund...
...and he would have about 750.
With that, you can do whatever you want.
That's the money for you to go out with your friends,...
...to go for drinks at bars, to buy him a present, to pay for your pet,...
...whatever it is that you wanna do...
...and frankly, why you work so hard to make your own money.
This is a great way to join your finances that keeps you free from fights...
...has a solid foundation and ultimately lets you live your richest life.